this program is brought to you by Emory
University Oxford is Emory
so Oxford gives students an opportunity
to start the baccalaureate education
here and then in the second part of
their time to move over to the Atlanta
campus declare a major there and focus
on whatever disciplinary field they
choose to specialize in but when they
start here on the Oxford campus it gives
an opportunity to spend that time in a
setting that is really a liberal arts
intensive spending is what we call it so
to understand their education not so
much as focused on developing a
disciplinary expertise but to honing
their critical skill critical reading
skills thinking skills writing skills
how they present themselves thinking
about ethical implications of their
learning that's what we focus on that
what becomes the content of our
education
[Music]
PPS L stands for theory practice
service-learning you go out into the
community you work with people last
semester was assigned to the Washington
Street Community Center where we tutored
kids after school and we learned about
the behaviors of the kids and how they
related with each other how the adults
related with the kids the first letter
in T PSLs theory so the whole idea is
that you're applying theories you learn
in class and they put there's a lot of
importance place on that at Oxford you
are giving tools to be successful in the
real world and TPS L is an indicator of
that like you're really being placed in
the real world to show what you have
learned in class the theories you have
learnt in class
[Music]
well in high school is a big research
netic and trying to figure out where I
was when I go to school I looked at over
30 schools narrow them down to 12
Northwestern Cornell Yale Dartmouth and
pretty much I chose Oxford because of
small class sizes it is unique and that
we are partnered with PhD level faculty
from day one teachers are collected here
because they want to teach freshmen and
sophomores and so they are clinicians
here doing research with all of our
biology teachers psychology teachers
students have co-authored papers this
summer hopefully I get to do some
research with one of our bio teachers
here
[Music]
for me at Oxford in the sciences one of
the real advantages is the students that
I teach in the classroom so I have 24
students in my cell biology and genetics
class I teach those 24 students in class
but also teach them in the laboratory so
those two teaching arenas for me or both
mine so I don't have a graduate student
or somebody else who teaches the land
for me and I can integrate them the
information in those two spheres for my
students I can work on their development
both as scientists and the way they
think scientifically as well as the
content knowledge from the students
perspective it means that the kind of
experience they have in the laboratory
is much richer so I can actually have
been doing independent projects guide
them as they do that not just research
students but every student introductory
biology is involved in two independent
student designs research project as part
of the laboratory program it wouldn't be
possible to do that if you were sort of
putting that out for someone else to
take care of
[Music]
I went to Oxford then I went to Emory
College I went to University of Michigan
as a grad student and I don't think I've
ever had a class that had more than 30
people to be able to have that kind of
intense undergraduate experience really
helped me as a graduate student that
helped me as a professor and I know as a
student that I felt the connection and
the passion that the oxford professors
had and I understand now as a faculty
member the importance of being able to
have those strong connections with
students being able to invite them into
your world and to help them understand
the world from a different perspective
[Music]
[Applause]
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University